apologies for absence yeah oh no sorry
emergency evacuation announcement in the
event of a fire or other emergency
please exit the building in an orderly
manner to the assembly point which is
located in the market carpark the fire
exit in this room is indicated by green
flags in sight
please do not delay the evacuation by
clicking on you belong you're not used
to lived the premises must not be
re-entered into a fire brigade I've
given the all-clear please notice
against the law to smoke on these
premises please note that this meeting
will be audio recorded if I could just
remind people to turn off their mobile
phones please
apologies for absence we have an apology
from councillor Dre and councillor milk
a substitute member is councillor merit
to the evening thank you minutes of the
meeting held on the 26th September 2017
already agreement with those to receive
declarations of interest please mehleb
an external auditor report updates for
2016-17 consider the report on section
one five one after drawing members
attention to D wives and your audit
letter
so it's just a recovering report to
summarize the the final report that you
I provided in terms of the 1617 accounts
obviously the members of this committee
have had quite a detailed discussion
around the auditor findings for 1617 at
the last audit committee so this is
really just a summary of that yeah the
final position so the annual D letter is
appended to to the covering reports and
that will be published on our website
for members of the public to review as
well after seguida this meeting so just
to remind members that there was yeah
we've got an unqualified and deletion on
our financial statements and yeah there
was no sort of substantive matters to
report as part of the the audit
committee and sorry the audit report
that was certain reported last meeting
so and I see no one's got any sort of
specific questions or concerns about any
of the contents of the Audion letter I'd
recommend we referring to delivery of
the QC saving pens at one point 0 for 1
million implementation of investment
remember proposal one for shortly and
savings and the pendrick's reserves of
30,000 pounds in 10 days of subjugating
thereafter concern is the middle one
values here
he referred to implementation of
investment end of member program
proposal awkward for me and savings are
we referring to income generation as
well or shouldn't we be and was founded
and you talk about romizi responded yet
so I'd have to double-check back but
Krista don't know if you want to say
we're referring to income generation or
didn't those the mechanized I haven't
all these have related to us I mean you
you could possibly refer to it as
sightings and income generation I think
you've Jim just use the catch-all phrase
for sightings which sort covers all the
plans that and quiets the gap but it's
exciting potential II you could choose
to call it though you're a combination
of the two but then so input up to that
thing for clarity is the 1.44 1 million
python 2.4 for 1 million plus 30,000
pounds the total about sorry that city
hasn't even eaten business what you need
to do SOTA 2 point 2 point 4 for 1
million is a total of savings and income
from investments we made to in the
following paragraph we refer to the
council assistance at 53% of pens have
gluten-free prospects on 35% a medium
risk is that of that 2.4 400 million
because that would think therefore
suggests to me that
and then 12% of that is not deliverable
or a high risk presumably yeah Chris do
you know that risk assessment was that
carried out by your team right I don't
know that that was our only the risk
assessment was carried out by Rob on
spreadsheet right providing the support
of the savings funds yes yes okay so
yeah obviously it's a there's a range of
savings pants over the next five years
and and of those obviously that
different ones would have been worked up
to different degrees and some will be in
their sort of more advanced state than
others so obviously there's a range of
sort of risk around those those being
delivered
so yeah it's probably right but there
was a yeah a range of them so is it safe
for me to issue I don't want to show me
things the 12% is high risk well this
was a snapshot at a point in time and
now as we always say the NTFS it's
always a bit of a me and moving them
face for things are always moving on in
the position where now I won't
necessarily reflect the position that
was done at this point last year
yeah I'm just just to recommend this is
this is based on the 2016-17 made
himself an extra stretch up see we're in
the 1718 now planning for the 1890s
there has moved on considerably since
then moved on considerably I'm just
concerned about later does he see
further those danyoung think we don't
need to worry about 12% of high-risk
when I'd I'm talking too much but where
did your math but I don't think it's
saying that we don't we do we don't need
to be concerned I think it's just an
enormous sight to Professor if you've
got an sort of a five-year plan that not
everything's gonna be assessed as being
completely deliverable at a point in
time there's going to be a range of
assumptions around the different risks
associated with proposals as their works
are favored in a period of time so I
think it's probably normal that there's
a range of risk exposures to some of
those savings plan Lisbon understand
that the only is I just sort of get
around on the sound that they mentioned
53% put delivery thirty-five sent me to
risk when I fail to mention the
remaining don't think I just want to
totally double concerns about that
Booker says that that's high risk which
we are including we've got twelve
percent of their income or saving which
is high risk
six point one seven couple mentions
where whatever we consider the 3-ton
forcing these assumptions be optimistic
that keeps coming nothing seems to not
change there's anything we can do so
it's going to that so evermore we all
turn yes I I think obviously we use well
we work with the Essex County Council
who provide pension evaluations and and
Sonia points and an actuary because it
bonnet wouldn't yeah-hoo-hoo provide the
analysis of the pension accounts as you
say Ernst and Young have their own views
about methodology used for that we have
had discussions both last year and
ongoing this year and I think the leader
and County Kevin McDonald is having
those conversations with E Y and others
and also between the actuaries
themselves about the assumptions
underpinning
evaluation of the pension but I think
it's something that's ultimately almost
out of our control we have raised it as
an issue but we're taking our best
independent advice from the actuaries
and and your wife just have slightly
different opinion about how they might
do it I think it slightly difficult for
us to say you know it's it's not just
about to be the same line in their each
time I think this is a summary of the
report that we took in September meeting
so this this is not reiterating that the
better still problems again we're
raising again as a problem is to we're
civilizing what we said that they're 17
after last year's well I think it was in
the letter
sign virtually the same language I think
it's just concerning that it keeps
coming up it doesn't seem to change it's
almost a difference of professional
opinion and if there's not an absolute
right or an answer so I think I mean
it's possible it could be raised again
this year with as I say we are seeking
to see if they can be resolved at a high
level but I think we just have to most
accept it at this point
the last item in the small item they're
related receivable with trails
information to treatment by the coast
1809 conclusion the expand madness to
understand fly in comparison minutes
concerning that he's kind of lost yes so
I I think the the additional fee that's
been charged has been from yeah for a
number of reasons which are listed in
that so I think the the delay in the
receipt of information was around a
couple of things but I don't think that
actually drive the the material change
in the fear to be wrong chriscommunity
because we've got a breakdown haven't we
of the additional fee into those four
different areas if I forgot it so hand I
can provide that to you afterwards I
don't know if you can recall some selves
in here at that time if there was a
particular issue about piece of
information that we couldn't provide
what I'm more interested in the root
cause of it because it is it something
that is actually ongoing or is it
something that has been sorted at all is
this something we'd like you to give a
different who's in future no well
obviously the auditors need a wide range
of information and we as officers
directs it best to provide that all in a
timely manner and you know as quickly as
possible and I suppose you saying our
own benefit as well because we want you
know to have an efficient audit process
and we don't want to be charged
additional fees I mean occasionally
there's pieces of information that might
take a bit more sort of work in terms of
you know looking back historically or
you know looking for our fires which
might take a bit of time and I can't say
with absolute confidence without going
back and checking what that particular
thing related to what it was but you
know it's possible and it on occasion
that it might take us a bit longer than
when we would hope to find it you know a
particular piece of information that the
auditors why would you expect this to be
under the
sort of umbrella of the ongoing staffing
issues as a psychic without names and
found exactly what that piece of
information was I don't know if it was
big because we're under resource to that
time or if it was just that we had
difficulty locating a particular you
know piece of information that the
auditors required
can you yes we this this what happened
with this is when we submitted at the
scale fee variation we provide a detail
report to officers at all councils to
say what the issues are and this case
Matt asked for a more detailed breakdown
further than that which would be
provided and this is to do with large to
do with family for money for money
we request for pollution or bath which
was to do with the mediums of financial
plan and these working papers supporting
supporting that information which was
late in coming and somewhere is why in
terms of the Green gateway in from
people money money area and there were
some areas on the accounts as well which
caused delays in terms of the
information coming back and forth it's
like these are with with offices what
and also with the early closed down
process this year we're having to
deliver Darrell disappeared she was to
july rather than september we're in a
process of talking and discussing issues
like this with with offices to try and
address and
the bottlenecks that occur so on
probably for money we're trying to
finish our we're completely by the 31st
of March because we should have I want
all the information to be able to do
that this year
and also on one encounter that the first
asset register which is another its
source of the income you know there's
been a long chain
so it's viable to try to address these
issues
ok so is this more of your being of
amenities from one because of the
changing circumstances on dates and the
request to receive format it's in it was
just specific to specific areas in terms
of the week we made requests the
information was like Queen back we
didn't go into details to why it was
late Queen back it's just know that he
was late coming back it takes an extra
time as far as a yet in all councils
that we deal with this is not some new
you identify but there can be delays in
certain areas yeah this was specific to
Pythian money and some areas on the
accounts as well
okay thank you I think cancel this
presentation 6:23 the last two
paragraphs are these procedures now
embraced accounts should put in place
receivers to identify the type the
counts of non-cancer workers clearly
identified this was in Malaysia then
like and need guidance see so we hope so
yeah we have got procedures in place in
terms of procurement for the they're not
Co I'm just trying to see what specific
which with into law did recommendations
from them
yeah so I think all in all the intent of
what was then contractors myself did you
want to say yes about basis it's
regarding the Tecla arrangements of the
local trading company that we have just
to make sure that 19 percent tech
arrangement is in place so keeping a
track of when what incomes coming near
to that to the trading company is within
the Tecla range minh so majority of the
income is from rush for District Council
and there was a few other smaller
contract
it's just keeping that along but it's
still working within tackle criteria
and that is being done and 626 again
long time era graphs incorrect entries
in the financial statements formula
yeah so folks advice um there is we're
obviously identified through last is
audit and her we've now got on place
procedures to address size to make sure
they don't really care and again that's
something it and so Lord it will be
looking at again this year as part of
their plan so that that will be sort of
rechecked again for compliance but we
have to put in place because he just to
make sure that those Arizona care again
this year and finally in this section
628 the IFRS 16 exercise requested by
all leases is s underway yes so yeah
we're um we've got an leaders in place
to make sure we're compliant with those
new regulations as well and there's
ongoing sort of advice being sought from
auditors and you know I'm from sit for
exemptions to make sure we're fully
compliant with Indian Standards once
there
recommendation is that is proposal which
resolves that the annual that all the
better for the year ended 31st of March
2017 be noted noted height um seven six
penalties recorded certificated play in
terms of terms and the report 1617 and
so separately to our main annual audit
there's also a separate audit that's
carried out each year which this year
was being carried out by the ey for
ourselves which is about certification
certification of their claims and
returns for housing benefits so it's
probably aware that we have to claim
from the Department of Work and Pensions
the housing benefits that we award to
eligible and residents so each year
those claims are checked in detail by
the auditors to make sure that they're
correct or if there's any errors
occurring under the scope of that work
they are required by legislation to
actually report on any error life and no
matter how sort of smaller immaterial
the value of that error is so the report
basically draws out that some errors
were found this year and the errors were
slightly more than has been the case in
previous years however I would like to
say that the amount of say the claim
that we make that to EE DWP is
over 17 million per annum and the actual
amounts that's fancy Hank found that we
needed to recover from that subsidy
payment was 777 pounds so the actual
value of the errors that were identified
through the testing work was very
immaterial compared to the actual value
of the claims I've said having said that
we obviously don't take any errors
likely so any particular areas of
testing that fans found anything of
concern and further testing was then
carried out to see if they thought Varys
was systemic and I think I've already
found that there wasn't any systemic
errors in our processes and procedures
but again here I will check that again
this year in check at the detail of
lights claims in this year and we have
also putting in place processes and
procedures to make sure what we address
any areas that of concern that were
found true and you don't found during
the audit again as a result of the extra
testing that I have to carry out the a
fee that was charged to us was slightly
higher than was indicated at the outset
of the audit and that was primarily
because they had to come in and do an
extra weeks worth of testing so there's
obviously additional resource associated
with with that and so theatrically it
was eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty three pounds are supposed to the
indicative fee of 8250 so yes again just
to recommend and I think the greater
time frame of then July and July and
this year that that testing will be
undertaken that point before the part of
the audit work that's going to be
carried out up in for this year the nice
area out by internal laundry it's all
another staffing State oh sorry yeah
it's combination of the team digs mental
tracking and then internal audits I
haven't come and doing this trip
checking presses strikes me that we're
kind of coming at this from the wrong
way doing testing rather than actually
making sure we don't make the mistakes
in first place I appreciate what you're
saying yeah on the tests it looks like
all the systems in there in place but
when we read something here where we see
2014 15 2015 16 there have been
increases each year does it no indicate
that there is maybe a lack of
understanding in this stuff maybe a bit
more training needed well we have quite
an experienced and team with quite a lot
yeah quite a lot of them you know
experience of doing this kind of work
and they do and do some sample checking
throughout and yeah you know you know
every and their week to check there's no
errors occurring on a sort and systemic
basis however yeah I think the nature of
their housing sort of benefit work is
very complex and and the rules are
always changing and there's always and
sort of new things to take into account
so I think we would say that we're not
overly concerned that there's a sort of
staffing training issue at this point in
time but obviously if we were to
continue to see the levels of Eric's
repeated again the following year I
think we might you know obviously start
to raise some alarm bells by I think it
was more than
some of the changes and supplies and
things that were coming in that actually
caused some of the issues this year it's
a place to actually start your 1 year
increase you put that down to two
changes well I mean it's difficult to
say absolutely what's causing the
increase year-on-year
but I think the fact that there's new
sort of them what's the right word and
yes so if the needs been some new
legislation that was been bought in this
year obviously then raises complexity of
the cases and I think just by their
nature the complex's and type of work
they haven't went eight undertake those
always give rise to the scope for some
errors to occur about there yeah so the
following year so because of the area's
we found last year that triggered us to
do further testing this year so testing
has been more in depth than we would
have done I'll ship because of our
errors so the more testing we do
inevitably the more errors you are going
to find so next year we will be doing
more testing than we have done this year
so there is likelihood that because
we're covering more there may be more
errors but I wouldn't expect them to be
large and just as knowingly said the
nature of the work there are going to be
small differences here and there
sometimes just a few pens that when
extrapolating do come out a bit larger
okay so when we've got as you say a
changing legislations and stuff like
that
how do you inform staff that if you find
out for yourself
now there's quite an a good system in
terms of well they're team leaders
obviously get some external training and
that is cascaded down throughout the
team and there I think there is a quite
good systems in place for sharing
information and making sure that all
officers are up to speed with any
legislative changes that do occur yeah
if I might just jump in knowing the
structure of the team is that the the
benefits manager Simon hybrid he will be
keeping on top of that legislation
passing down to his supervisors if it's
training that can be done you know if
it's a minor change in legislation it
can be done internally if there's some
major changes that are happening
nationally then we'll bring in a trainer
in the example we've got an external
trainer in today and tomorrow doing some
training for the whole team on a number
of issues that the changes coming forth
so it's the nature of the beast
it's however much legislation is
changing determines the amount of
training requirement I would I mean I
would act at any given time we're
talking about over 3,000 active cases
that they're dealing with quite quite a
lot of it and complex situations that
require maybe two or three changes per
day to be looked at
unfortunately in it in any field like
that there's going to be an element of
human human error
no matter how much training you throw
one of the properties talked about
benefits of five weeks in a month where
the computer system can't come it's like
if you re a dress from the universal
credit screen because the me issues
there anybody with you but I'm not
buying into issues what it was but
already in spoken like a computer system
couldn't identify look it was five
Mondays in the month it's playing
completely kaput now that's just one
person
how many more could you have like that
yeah as much as the staff have training
their upgrades to the system comes every
we've just put in three upgrades this
month so every time they gestation
changes have to have to put another
upgrade in for the Academy system to be
to be changed but something like that
I'm gonna fight my fighters into new
it's that mean forever so I have to look
at that and see why I wasn't aware of
that so I can look at that specifically
outside and come back to you that's fine
this is so that now so uh we were doing
this but that was one person I was just
concerned right that you could be on
people another slide please
this issue for Christmas that's where we
found it I think where there are wider
issues like that it yeah I say we're
relying on their systems provider to
provide a solution because it's going to
affect all potential claimants see yeah
okay thank you I'm here just like you
just confirmed that capita are still
doing that right great
hello when I when I say capita Academy
isn't is a capital product we have to
face the software not any other
questions thank you very much the
recommendations recommendation is that
it's proposed that we resolves the
certification of claim return which
won't be no just a little bit happy to
consider the report in the section 151
officer presenting the counseling tunnel
which does anyone read thank you
so yeah Anthony I never again we're
going to be paying out our audit for 17
18 accounts and as I discussed
previously at these meetings most we
aware that their timetable for that work
has been brought forward so and being
quite a lot of work to prepare a plan
that will enable us to meet our revised
statutory deadline which means I'll
cancel to be signed off by the end of
July and so the report is appended to
the cover covering statement and sets
out how a wide place to work with us to
make sure and all the Edit formed it
work is completed
by the statutory time frame the fee for
the work this year is currently proposed
as four to seven thousand six hundred
fifty seven however as a result of and
some additional testing work that's
going to need to be carried out
following on from the results of the
1617 audit there may be some additional
fees associated with that additional
testing again so that fee could rise
slightly so really at this stage it's
just to note that there's a plan in
place and again if there's any questions
members would like to ask about that
plan myself and crystals will help them
move out set property plant and
equipment valuations and the pension
valuation are going to have the same
problem so I think when the pensions one
I can't really add a lot to what I said
earlier this and we've raised the issue
both with this kind of counts or and
vaporized it with the actuary so I think
we're aware of the issue we've raised it
and there's not a lot more we can do at
this stage but potentially the same
issue could arise again on their
property plant and equipment valuation
it's a similar a similar issue I think
as we discussed at last Audit Committee
and that it's almost a difference in
professional opinion between the
external value R and E wise an internal
opinion about how how the actual basis
and value evaluations resume as arisen
and what I would say is we have we are
putting in place a rolling plan of what
assets we are having
revalued so we're just undertaking that
work at the moment
and potentially not all of our assets
will need to be very valued every year
so we're doing on a proportionate places
so I wouldn't expect that the same sort
of level of issues should potentially
arise this year just purely because
we're not having all of assets we valued
every year now so so the issues should
be slightly less from that perspective
but I think the the under little line so
the underlying issue around how the
valuations arrived at hasn't disappeared
subjects a quick one six ounce of
savings they don't believe in turn
invisible million okay okay this refers
to the work area both going to be around
to make the savings DubLi how was offset
previously in them in the empty faces
sort of indicates there will be a
combination of savings up and all
returns from income through the
investment therefore mainly there's no
mention of that side of it done so
technology issue potentially we could
live to seek to ask the auditors to
change the wording around that just so
it's clear that there's potentially
income generation as well as saving very
much yes okay well make that change
thank you calories thank you we
shouldn't quite a few talked about the
pension fund
Andy's mentioned specifically the
deficit what is the deficit actually
standing at the moment do we know haha
thanks to me and the deficit for this
scheme as a whole and was reported to us
at our six planets offices meters I have
got some slides that set out their
position so it's probably best if I I
just checked on allowed circulate I
don't think they're confidential so it's
probably best if I circulate those to
you after the meeting said and you'll
have Lices position but can you give us
a rough idea
and I can just have a quick look um I
like to see that this is County and so
we're part of the Essex County scheme so
it we're we're a member of that scheme
so the deficit is calculated for the
scheme as a whole we don't have an
individual deficit as an individual
participating Authority as part of that
scheme so I can't I won't be able to
give you an individually thinking we
must have some sort of an indication of
how much our as a council deficit is as
a proportional things figure that you
I'm not absolutely sure that we do I can
I can take that away and check but
basically all the individual members of
the scheme are sort of aggravated by the
actuary and they come up with a position
in terms of what how the scheme is
funded overall but I'm not sure if they
do come back to us with an individual
breakdown power authority and abroad and
on this one this is really strange I
understand from a previous meeting that
our payments were completely up to date
yes so yeah I think it's two issues yes
yeah the way the pension schemes valued
is about looking at the complete total
assets of the speed which includes all
the component members and the complete
liabilities and obviously those
liabilities stretch you know many years
into the future so the actuaries have to
forecast how much pensions will have to
be paid out over a long period of time
and then they have to invest all the
money to make sure that returns going to
be sufficient to pay those pension
liabilities many years into the future
so there's a slightly different issue
around how they then ask for authorities
to contribute to the scheme so I'll see
each individual makes a pension
contribution as part of their paying
package and obviously ideally the those
pension contributions should completely
fund this game I think over time a
deficit has arisen
across all a local government pension
schemes which means that the the assets
this game has in place on sufficient to
necessarily fund all if you
liabilities so where that deficits
arisen eyes up they've asked for
individual authorities to make a
contribution to make up that gap so we
have made an additional contribution as
have all their participating authorities
in the scheme to help bridge that and
that's the part that we're completely
up-to-date to and so we have we have
made an additional contribution to the
scheme to make sure that yeah obviously
this games able to pay its pension
liabilities into the into the future but
yeah we're far from unique all local
government pension schemes are in the
same situation essentially so in your
estimation then use the risk going up on
this one again it's it's a difficult
once again the sort of black and white
answer on and the overall liabilities of
the scheme are rising over time as
obviously their population ages and the
members of the scheme age so what the
scheme loves to do is to try and address
that through making sure the
contribution levels are right and that
the assets the scheme investing to fund
that are going to give the right return
to enable us to mate to make those
payments in the future so it's quite a
it's quite a complex and picture so it's
difficult to say absolutely but
obviously as part of their work they do
the arteries and the screen make
projections about what they think that
deficit could look like in future years
and the aim is to close that gap so that
the scheme is is is funded into the
future I understand what you're saying
but I mean to use the analogy of this
council we don't know where we're going
to be in a few years time because the
risks and the things that might happen
it's the same with the pension but we do
have a snapshot of whether we're ready
yeah we have nothing as an audit
committee we have no idea where we are
at with this deficit and I think that's
not good hmm we should have that
information well well I could take ways
to and I see I wasn't prepared to do
sort of them updates tonight back and
bring back and update paper which sort
of sets out the position in terms of the
scheme as a whole and and where we are
at to their to the next meeting if that
would be
two members just say butter that's my
understanding of the position yes thank
you can we be assured that there's no
mismanagement of those opponents and yes
I think as far as don't see how I've got
absolutely no reason to just to think
that this games being mismanaged in any
way there's quite tight controls around
how the pension schemes operates and
obviously there's a pension and board
that either has either site off off of
that that similarly to this audit
committee provides independent insurance
that the schemes being managed and
prudently prudently so there's no
absolutely no reason to suggest that the
schemes being mismanaged in any way oh
no a liability is proportional as the
individual councils are proportional or
is it as a whole no I say there's the
screen isn't funded on an individual
authority basis so that the the assets
and the liabilities are shared among
elderly payment authorities which yeah
okay that was an individual country but
we seem to be talking about it very much
within just coming down I would see them
and obviously we have very involved here
how those charges actually split because
it looks like we're actually is the
council being charged for all the only
thing that is being done for Green Bay
Park well we have a recharge arrangement
in place whereby we charged the cost of
any time spent supporting Greenway Green
gateway which includes the sort of audit
charge associated with that so Green
gateway do you get a proportionate
charge for the world it's undertaken on
their behalf so and yeah I don't think
can we have a year something for 19
future please and yes there is actually
paper that's going to investment board I
think which is publicly available on
there and on the web is it not
I was it appears anyone okay well I'll
have to if it's PNC I might have to take
it away and see well we don't need it I
think for the future it's something the
audience there is going to be I say more
an in-depth audio as part of next is and
it's just so I'll just suddenly hear
that cuz these will have access to that
report
yeah the investable reports for tomorrow
evening
all members will be able to access
including the confidential ones if that
helps yes there is a breakdown of the
accounts that asking for free gateway to
know each other
I've just been appreciated it confirmed
it as well because obviously this is
something X financial is a risk and we
should be looking at it it should be all
about very poor tal result I think just
just to emphasize though the the
external audit of group accounts is more
from the Rochford point of view I is
Rochford preparing its statutory
accounts incorporating GGT yet as part
of that account it's not auditing Green
gateway trading as mentioned an awful
lot you curious overly because they're
there with 100 percent shareholder off
you are a hundred percent shareholder of
that company but Chris and the team will
be all getting the Roger inside of the
group of cows they're not going to be
looking at green guideways accounts per
se as a company at home as a group okay
one last one
section 18 threshold reporting any
issues they're set 364,000 she's done a
percentage basis
364,000 are we saying them that if we
found my if it was found to be a problem
on anything that was they say three
hundred and sixty three hundred fifty
thousand but it wouldn't actually be
something that would be highlighted to
be reported and well I don't know Chloe
wants a comment on that and but I think
it would not necessarily be reported but
I think it wouldn't necessarily be
flagged as a material risk to the
misstatement of the accounts but it
depends on the nature of the yarra that
was potentially found that that that
that's applied with some discretion for
us to give us or to professional beneath
which you know the materiality might not
be judged to be as significant what
we're saying is that if it's over that
threshold
it's definitely reported if it's under
under that threshold and it's found then
it is a decision as to whether it's
reported or not is that always that well
I'll let Chris comment I had like my
vase or the oldest used to interpret
that beneficial yes on that for sure
particularly I think if it's a
corrective if it's a retraction to the
accounts we would report on that a month
item if it's over that yes we may have
discretion if it's just under that son
to to report we can report on that we
don't we're not we're not this don't
harm us
something else in it because we may wish
to report if we become do but generally
as a rule which was born 364 that three
to four thousand pounds if the council
amend their accounts if the council
choose not to amend their accounts we
have a lower limit there 56,000 pounds
at which we would report support thirty
six thousand pounds of the cast did not
put them in their accounts thank you
I think mr. Pickwick question is a
simulation screen grab the green paper
training dummies
I ask the same question I think either
last meeting waiting for the answer ease
that the costs our relation to the
preparation of the council's
consolidated accounts to consolidate
Green Bay we're trading into those
accounts not anything which is a cost to
the council not cost in relation to
Greendale itself correct
that's easy somewhere by car I'll try to
find it by college one which means he
was a loser last week's me break might
be the jeweler thank you
that's mine fact page 0.7 Fitness right
spells additional risks for 2017-18
what exactly yeah that's around the
methodology that we've used previously
we sort of let our books had and Eve and
carry out that work on behalf of the
council so they have their own
methodology about how they arrived at
our business rates appeals provision and
we've taken the decision this year and
partly because the fee for that work was
quite high that we could do that work
internally ourselves any change in how
you calculate a particular element of
the council to see leads to increased
risk from the audience's point of view
that change could lead some potential
errors so I think that's something in
life like up as part of a plan I'd want
to just to take a closer look at this
year's make sure that the methodology
we're using is is robust because
previously it was carried out by the or
external
but I think we're confident that we've
gotten a good process in place that it's
gonna give us a robust estimate so I I'm
I'm happy that the methodology raising
is robust it's just because it's
actually changed from the one that we
used last year that the auditors have
taken an interest in that no the audit
is happy with what you've put in place
and well obviously I haven't done the
work yet but we have been consulting
with them to make sure that you know
what we're doing seems reasonable but
obviously they'll have to do carry out
their own testing work before they can
form an opinion on that and that I don't
know if you had I suppose you can't
really say anything at this stage
recommendation for that disease proposal
the committee results of the audit plan
or 1718 keynote thank you this is the
internal audit progress report we
consider the report of the assistant
director democratic services which draws
members attention to competing for all
different agents and provides and
updates of audit recommendations Thank
You Jen thank you
I just noticed a slight error in law
report I state I completely have
completed five audit reviews since
committeeman September there's actually
six so and these are detailed appendix
one which is my 26 in this report and I
need to draw
committee's attention to two of these
all its environmental health and a waste
management contract as both these
received a limited audio pin you I'll
briefly explain why we gave a limited
assurance opinion in relation to both
those audits thank Evora mental health
first we examined three areas in
relation to the ability we looked at
food hygiene
air quality and health and safety
to external security between his area we
have no concerns in relation to the
areas that have the safety and air
quality this knot cannot be said in
relation to food hygiene the problems
around the food hygiene stem from a
reduced staffing i'm the lincoln post an
extended staff sickness this is
excessive aided by an IT system that is
not fit for purpose as resources have
been directed to reactive work the
council's not being able to meet its
obligation for prompt inspection and has
been relying upon external contractors
complete is that shatori food inspection
program for the past three years but
move on to waste management and why we
gave a limp in the short span your
agency's earlier contract management
activities is primarily focused where
data is readily available rather than
within confirmed high risk or high
impact areas the contractor supplies a
computer system to manage general
complaint issues regard contract
performance but recorded that is only a
valuable in RAW format and this limits
management from effectively recognizing
trends linking issues are focused in
contract management monitoring efforts
the contractors performance said those
generally being satisfactory but this is
not formally documented due to limited
performance indicator accorded several
important operational aspects of the
contract have not been actively and
consistently managed these include
confirming the contractor has effective
business continuity arrangements in
place seeking assurance but relevant how
the safety reforms have been met and
he's sure an appropriate assurances are
in place also a time to be Audion the
council didn't have a business
continuity plan to build the contractor
failure in terms of the contractor going
out of business this list this matters
now been roamin remedied in terms
actually we now have a draw business
continuity plan in place
redlight today she's based now I'll talk
about staffing in terms of the resources
available to carry out the audit plan
the Uganda team is essentially bent down
to bun member earthstar
since June 2017 attempts have been made
to plug the gap of resources from
bathroom and from next week a member of
the thousands of teams be on site 14
full time to ensure daily review audit
plan for 2017-18 we also in the process
of going out for a full-time permanent
position to fill the vacant post okay
you can just remove up the next part of
my are my reports at around reported
recommendations provisions making the
audit plan follow up on what
recommendations made these days have
provided appendix 3 9.20 one of the
things are likely audit committee to
consider at this point I'm whether you
are happy with that level of detailed
information in relation to other
recommendations as it takes quite a
considerable amount of time to put
together or whether you just like an
overview terms a number of
recommendations made against how many
outstanding how many implemented I'm
quite happy to continue to probe the
level of detail as is but I would like
committee to consider what the
information I'd like going forward I'm
finding I'd like to talk about counter
fraud at present it was limited work
sorry at present the work is limited to
work undertaken but in compliance team
the consideration to fraud is also given
performance of the audits we undertake
during the year the compliance team
continue to deliver good results I've
reported 22 cases of fraud have been
identified with a reported value of over
nineteen thousand pound and I'm quite
happy any questions in relation to my
mobile thank you honey so many questions
other than just reflect having spoken to
Martin environmental health manager
about this report and some of the
concerns that were raised either the
particular agency difficulties with the
IT system that they use to actually
cause the environmental health work and
also in terms of the staffing issues
here Martin's explained to me that
they've had of the three food officers
at they've had one is left and one's
been off long time to sick actually
Martin good see he's in the person of
recruiting to wear those posters now and
indeed they've actually shortlisted this
week one of those patients so I'm
hopeful I think it's a fair election the
IT issues in the workforce issues you
mentioned in further sort of very
variable that you're very happy with the
council's air quality management program
and you can tell they nearly as well
control can you explain to us what that
actually does how much testing goes on
there are a number of slides from three
of authority where there's static
measures and also there's I suppose
ongoing measurement of air quality
throughout the district so I the council
yes can we see those results Thanks
there's a report that goes to a website
that the results are uploaded to an
essex the results reported through two
chances city council who produce a
report on our behalf
the results are about really wave of yes
there are they can you send me a link
for that please I think I can yes
she waiting on the December 2 future
results to come back to him he just put
the question that way yeah it's not
actually make it doesn't work so would
you like a decision on that now whether
all that you'd like to continue yeah
that'll be I think I think I'm hearing
that how do members feel that other
happy for that to continue
I am certainly council boy thank you
just going back to the results you so we
don't have a member from Hazelden
working for us until when did you say
this it six-month contract moment but
he'll be I'm sufficient time to basic
you're completely already planned with
2017-18 yes and just for clarification
when we're talking about on here the
time scales for the original get we
talked about four to one talk to all we
talk about financial year Porter one
yeah the phone calls one would be from
April tonight yes that's right correct
and called for would be from January
January to do tomorrow we're now
apparently quarter before yes so this
report should cover everything up to
call two three yes yes so how far are we
behind you the order to the monument I
think yeah boys anyway because because
we back end or back load the the audit
plan I think mainly we are currently on
track but then we will devote thermal
resource that deliver in the plan
there's nothing that's known in my view
the plan will be delivered and then
there are two or three audience that
will be deferred to 2018-19
because they currently can't be
undertaken because the basic changes in
in this service structure so there are
two or three audits that war
original plan that won't be delivery
because they will be deferred because we
can't carry those out coz at the moment
would keep it into insurance vineyard so
new police and procedures are being
embedded so we won't actually on state
those reviews and until 1819 when that
the new changes have been embedded but
the plan will be delivered as they're
set out so we are on course to deliver
the order plan
sorry gonna be lost so we are on course
to different to deliver the audit came
apart from two or three yeah which we
come we were planned to look up look at
the start performance and management of
development area but a new appraisal
system is only recently being rolled out
so we're going to give that a chance the
bendi the school is going to get safer
recruitment but the new policy is only
launched in October 2017 so again we're
gonna basically come back in together
with Senator Johnson debating I suppose
- just - is it yeah sorry on the in
March 2017 when we did the object
playing for 1718 we included full
contract mention areas one of which I
think we've done which one there's a
proven to be a performance based
management the other ones we were we
were going to be looking at Malaysia
services IT support services and street
scene well they all be done in quarter
fall then are we saying they're hidden
audit plan we haven't granted those yes
called perform that seems rather
important it on the run in addition we
were looking at information technology
to understand program of assurance
reviews of key risk areas okay so I
think we've already have a couple of
Frisco is tonight already wanting them
to have ribs and things although we've
had three updates yeah which makes other
problem but council Shaw was saying
about the program alignment to recognize
there's five of Monday's in a month
sometimes I think it happens which was
the year he probably five mondays and
also heard about seven
with writing problems socially asset
equality corneria it's that also going
to be done portal we currently out
getting quotes from a couple of audit
firms in relation to the IT project
example taluka that we have had one go
back already which we have authority
cannot afford to be to be fair we have
got another fact we are waiting a very
quite on moment we if we were if we're
unable to go down those routes because
of cost we actually won't take work
in-house or and we have actually
developed a number questionnaires in
terms of put into edge you sir who
manage our contract so we will be either
undertaken internally or if there are
sufficient funds available we we will
engage a contractor so there are two
there were two quite cells to actually
engage external parties to undertake
that work and we're going to be reviewed
the cost of such but you believe that
will be that work they need be
undertaking yeah you have that we've
done even if it's not on the soon for
the basis dates will be done suite
myself and Jim has put together a series
of questions to put to a tree serve and
also new ground provider so we won't go
down that right route and put those
questions
Thibault veggie serve and the cloud
provider or we will engage outside party
depending on costs yes let me on I can
give you a figure I mean what one firm
is probably fifty thousand four right
yeah I think you're suggesting is
probably what could be a specialist area
I think it is this review committee also
have not seen two years I understand it
as well
interesting they were the the main
questions are could you just expand on
the cancer fraud and yeah it's on the
counter fraud work is basically limited
to diverse and compliance things that
surround benefits and counsel telling us
rich this council in relation to for
what it is is quite low you don't have
your own house and stock estimate where
I can know anywhere so it turns to the
risks most of the work is actually done
by the compliance then it relates to
council tax we occupy a national fraud
exercise which is basically a two year
exercise where we submit data sets to
the NFI and they come back a result and
they highlight to you these the cases
you need to look out the even might be
potential fraud doesn't mean there is
fraud then it's the task of the resident
been steamed to look at those results
and say yes it's wrong I'm not fraud and
then we will take appropriate action to
either recover the overpayment sum up 24
penalty well we also have shared
resources through through better than we
have a count for all team so if you
chose to bring criminal prosecution and
we could do that but at present watch is
not undertaken criminal prosecutions but
in the future you could do that if you
chose to do so but sometimes the value
of the overpayment products health
information to a council attack to
single person discount will be about a
thousand pound and you you prosecute
never cost you three to five thousand
that's the risk assessment so basically
to recover the overpayment stop the
overpayment from criminal prosecute
which I want Brady's next few ways that
better better leading everything thank
you very much good stories do you know
Kate and the other cats were so many
questions
thank you very much the recommendation
is this proposal the committee resolves
that the update on delivering the 1718
audit plan set out in the appendix a
includes the conclusions and results
completely all these engagements and the
updated status of all these recognitions
recommendations be noted is that duly
noted
thank you very much officers thank you
very much for attending councillors
thank you our meeting is closed the 2035